there's one jeff bezos there's one he's
right there
almost trillionaire hey jeff come here
man hey man
the way you build your self architecture
and the way you see yourself in the
world
is in part through your words one of the
most surprising things about doing this
podcast
is i learned how to talk to people
better yeah
i didn't think that was a thing wanna be
happy
build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so today let's live your
best believe
life and learn how to be a better
communicator
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one learn to listen with joe rogan
one of the most surprising things about
doing this podcast is i learned
how to talk to people better yeah i
didn't think
that was a thing i thought i just just
was talking to people but then i
realized somewhere along the lay
way not only are people listening but
sometimes i'm annoying okay
how do i how do i do this where i'm less
annoying
and in learning how to do things that
are less annoying i become a more
compassionate conversationalist i
understand how to talk to people
better and i've gotten it's i apply it
to my whole life now
i've gotten better at it and i see
people who are bad at it
it's so frustrating like i have some
really smart friends
and you know i talk to them and they
just interrupt each other and they
interrupt
you and they don't let anybody talk
they're not listening they're just
waiting for their time to talk and
it's it's so strange they're not able to
ever consider other people's opinions
they think that everyone but them
is wrong and it's you know it's
basically like
you know how it is when you see a
youtube video where people have no idea
how to fight and you see them fight
you know that thing that is so crazy
i've
to this day i'm like i've been doing
martial arts my whole life i don't want
to fight anybody
but i see people fighting they have no
idea how to fight them like i
imagine myself if i was in a street
fight with this guy i'm like this is i
would be like why are you doing this man
this is so crazy you don't know what
you're doing hey yeah hey you're crazy
you're gonna get killed you're lucky i'm
nice
but that's the same way with
conversation there's a lot of people out
there having conversations have no idea
how to talk they don't they're not even
really listening to you
yeah they're just so and like why are
you doing it why are you arguing
you're you're in a conversation you
don't even know how to have one
yeah you're not listening you're just
talking you're just using someone like a
like a wall that you're throwing a
tennis ball off of it's
bizarre i mean if you're really into the
sport of just
debating people and shutting people down
and insulting people okay
they're good for you but people don't
like listening to that that much yeah
what people like listening to for what
i've m from my experience
is someone actually talking to someone
someone actually expressing
their thoughts and then the other person
considering their thoughts and either
agreeing or disagreeing but
people are so happy when you could do
that without real
conflict yeah you know i've had some
people on that
just five years ago i would have i would
just said you
[ __ ] i would have screamed at them what
are you talking about
you're an idiot you can go [ __ ] yourself
jump off a bridge but instead of doing
that i'd be like okay why do you think
that
and tell me tell me what about this yeah
and then and
here's what i think let me tell you what
i think you tell me what you think i
think it's so
valuable so valuable for me it's just
for me
i know it's valuable for people that are
listening but just for me as a human
from my own education
it's been everything yeah everything
i've i've learned more from talking to
people
on this podcast both from talking to
scholars and
scientists and and really intelligent
people and morons
yeah you know i've learned a lot from
talking to morons just
just the awkwardness in the way they
process thoughts and the way they view
the world and
the way they've chosen to communicate
you learn from that just like you're
saying like
sparring with someone who's like doing
has terrible habits
yeah you go oh look at this guy what the
[ __ ] are you doing man yeah but you
learn
you can learn from people you learn so
much from these people
because of the way you're able to
communicate with them the way you're
able to
bring out conversation and and get in
depth
with all of these subjects well i'm
genuinely curious
about most things and i'm genuinely
curious about the way i think
i'm like why do i think that way so if
someone thinks different than me
i'm genuinely curious like why do you
think there's an instinct to go nah
you're
wrong i'm right but i i just go oh i
know what that is that's a trick
don't do that that's that's dumb don't
think that way
just try to find out this is not a game
it's not a contest yeah find out why
this person thinks this way
and it's better for everybody yeah
but it's just a lost talent like a lot
of people don't and i didn't even know
it was a thing
so i started doing podcasts it just took
me a while like
podcasts are like anything else for me
at least as i'm doing it
i'm trying to get better at it and i
realize oh i used to not be as good
like i can't i never listen to my
podcast but if i did listen to like the
old ones from the beginning i probably
like
yeah terrible jesus christ you know plus
most of them i was high out of my
mind i don't know half what i was
talking about while i was saying it
that was ruining conversations left and
right but
these conversations for me are like it's
like going to school
it's like every day i'm going to school
about humans
rule number two get your precision of
language right
with robin sharma i was on an aircraft
last weekend and here's what i heard
someone say
the flight attendant walked down
through the cabin and said to one of the
passengers
oh i'm so sorry i didn't ask
to hang up your coat and here's what the
reply from the gentleman was
oh don't be silly don't be silly
and the way that landed on me was
i know he was trying to be gracious but
he literally told
someone that they were silly
and i see this everywhere someone very
close to me
who was a little sloppy with her
languaging said
oh i forgot to do this punch myself in
the face
and i very lovingly said can i offer an
insight
look at the words you just used
think about that here's someone saying
oh i forgot to do this it's not on my
to-do list
i should punch myself in the face if you
say that every day what's that doing to
your self-esteem
you say that over a lifetime what's that
doing to your self-identity
and as you know if you followed me on
previous episodes your income
is a function of your self-identity
and your performance is a reflection of
your personal story
and the way you build your self
architecture and the way you see
yourself in the world
is in part through your words
you're never going to rise any higher in
terms of your impact
in the world than the way you see
yourself if you see yourself as average
well you're not going to read the books
go to the events do the study
put in the training time find the
mentors do the work
to rise to world class because you're
running an interior
psychological story that says
you're average and the a players are
somehow different from you
if deep down inside you're coming from
scarcity and you think you know what
i'll never
have more than the salary that i'm
making
because of the story that you have
through the words you've used
well then you're not going to go out
there and ask for the big order you're
not going to go
start the big business you're not going
to read the books on
financial mastery because deep inside
you would say
what would be the point i'm not one of
those people and if you want to rewire
your self-identity so you go in the
world
and you're literally operating at
legendary then you absolutely must
dial into this first point of what
legendary leaders do in terms of the way
they speak
which is get your precision of
languaging
right i'm no master i'm not
perfect i'm flawed i'm a human being
but one thing i get right is i'm very
calibrated
about the words i use because like i say
the great leaders
how did they transform humanity it was
through their words
how did the great military generals get
their armies
to go out there on fire it was through
their
words words can free nations and as we
know from history
words from evil leaders have
destroyed humanity caused brutality
words are that powerful also if you want
to have more confidence check out my 254
series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below you're i love you but i'm not
going to cut my arm off or you're
telling me to be a whole different human
being to be with you
and so stop resisting i encourage you
stop resisting the natural flow
of epic performance stop resisting
the natural seasons of life everybody's
successful lays the blueprint out
you laid the blueprint out rule number
three create a sense of belonging with
chamillionaire
early i used to be the guy that would
always be in everybody's ear
telling them everything i thought they
should do but i realized that you gotta
you kind of gotta hide the medicine
inside of kennedy
you know because people will um often
like uh
you know rebel from that you know they
don't want to be around that it's like
oil and water you know it feels like
you're you're uh
looking at them and judging them and you
know you think you're better than them
all these different things so
even though it was rooted and wanting to
see people actually succeed
it actually came off wrong to people but
it was just in my nature
i guess it was from my parents they used
to do it you know and i feel like
i was uh helping people but then over
time i started to learn the
better approach the the way to like lead
people to the water but not force them
to drink it you know and i felt like
that was way more effective but when you
start to grow and you start to
you know see things sometimes you know
you lose people i have friends that
never left the north side of houston
like they've never seen the other side
of the city
and you know somebody could laugh at
that to me that's like man you you don't
have ambition to want to see that side
some of them are like nah i'm stuck in
my ways and they feel like they're doing
it for real reasons they're keeping it
real and staying so loyal
to this thing that raised them but it's
like you can still be loyal to your
side of town by knowing what the other
side is about matter of fact
you might know how to help your side
even better by understanding what's
happening on the other side
you know but saying this to somebody uh
sometimes can come off wrong you have to
find out how to communicate so i've
always had that
struggle with how to communicate things
that i think are valuable to people
and over time i feel like rapping kind
of taught me that you know it taught me
how to
articulate my thoughts because you're
seeing a lot of things and you're going
to music to explain it to our audience
of people and you have so many different
types of people that you're talking to
you know you got some people that come
from the background that you come from
you got some people that
have no idea what you're talking about
and everything's foreign to them but how
do you articulate these things to people
and get everybody to care about it
i think people can focus on your passion
they can tell when you're authentic
all these things you start to hone in on
and get really really good at and then
people will start to listen you know
i used to go to this church on the north
side and there was a
guy one time that um was a pastor
and he used to have braids and he used
to come in and he used to talk to us
just like he was one of us
and everybody used to listen to him and
the other guys would come and they'd
have the button ups and nobody listened
to them and i saw that over and over and
i was just like
he's a pastor just like he's a pastor
but everybody listens to him because he
he
felt like he was just one of us he used
to play basketball with us he said to
all these things
and i always had these things wrestling
in my head because you know you almost
feel like you're not
you don't belong a lot of times in all
these different places you know as an
african-american kid in the city
you know you're in certain areas and
people are looking at you like you don't
belong
you go to church and they're looking at
you like what are you doing here because
you show up with a hoodie i remember one
time they were
having an open gym and i wanted to help
all these kids in the city come and uh
you know um have a place to play
basketball so i spent a lot of time
putting up the basketball goals doing a
lot of stuff and then i went home to get
you know
washed up so i could come back and play
basketball and then i come back and they
wouldn't let me in
and they're like excuse me sir this is
only for the members of the church and
i'm like
i just spent the whole day putting up
this and i was i was so mad i was like
arguing with this guy that
wouldn't stop me and then that guy with
the braids came in i was like no no and
let you know and it's just that little
understanding of welcoming you know what
i'm saying that
i kind of saw sometimes and when i would
see example of that i would try to be
that
and try to be like you know what i'm
gonna be more of like not trying to
judge people
and trying to help them be uh the best
that they can be and it started
transitioning to music and then it
transitioned to entrepreneurship
and then it just it just became
something that now is just like my day
daily life you know rule number four
captivate with patrick bay david
when i think about a great public
speaker this is my number one
let me tell you what my number one is if
i can go
and hear somebody speak okay whoever it
is
any one of these guys if i can go and
hear somebody speak
and the entire time uh michelangelo are
you still good with this if i cross my
okay the entire time when this person is
speaking
if i go hear somebody speak and i feel
like
he the audience could have thousands of
people in the room but i feel like it's
just me and this person speaking
that to me is a great speaker if it's
just you and i
that to me is a great speaker if i get
lost
during his speech and i forget everybody
else is in the room
i forget i'm watching a video i forget
i'm watching a movie
i'm watching like for instance when when
gladiator when gladius maximus russell
crowe gives out one speech
no one exists and you're just in the
movie you are
there or when you know uh braveheart
uh uh what's his name braveheart uh uh
uh uh
uh william while mel gibson gets up and
he gives out one speech with the whole
you know william wallace when he gives
that speech i mean you watch that
no one exists right or you hear denzel
washington
give a talk in john q my son is not
gonna i'm not gonna bury my son my son's
gonna bury who me
you're lost it's boom it's one person
right if a speaker knows how to do that
they all do it in their own separate
ways that to me is a great speaker
okay so if you can captivate me to the
point where i think it's just you and i
as if you and i have a cup of coffee
or we're having lunch and i'm simply
listening to you speak you've already
won
you don't even need to watch the rest of
the video turn off the video and skip to
another video you don't
watch anything else if you learn how to
do that the rest is over with
okay rest is over with because all the
other stuff you pick up by doing so many
times of speaking
you'll get better at it and rule number
five the last one before very special
bonus clip
is just do it with kevin hart i was in a
room with jeff bezos
and uh robert kraft this was the the
patriots that won the super bowl
and we're we're in like the this little
private room after
and tom brady is like giving a speech
thanking robert
uh for all robert thanks tom and i'm
with my wife and a friend
and jeff bezos walks in
and my friend go they go with jeff bezos
i said oh [ __ ]
i would love to pick his brain that's an
interesting individual
no don't do that what do you mean don't
do that
who said don't do my friend no no no no
don't do that
why are you talking about why are you
gonna do that kevin there's a room full
of people don't look like the dude
that's
thirsty thirsty for what
for information face
[Laughter]
we're going to like little we got into
like a little smack for what
information i want to say hey i want to
see my face i want to ask him some
questions
i ain't going to see this man no more i
don't know him we're not on a phone
number to phone number basis
i'm going to say what's up to him i
can't do you i'm just saying and this
environment just chill
it's relaxed and that should start to
click to me that's the problem
everybody's too cool everybody's too
cool right everybody wants you to think
that they know you don't know
you don't know we don't know there's one
jeff bezos
there's one he's right there almost
trillionaire hey jeff
come here man hey man first of all
explain the trillion to me what is that
how many zeros
what is that first of all do you know
how excited he must be to talk to you
too
who knows i'ma find out
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it out you know what i did joe what
hey man i'll be right back babe come on
took my wife with me hey jeff i'm kevin
hart how you doing man
hey kevin how are you jeff this is my
wifey nico
hey hey man i admire you
i don't know anything about that world
and death
but i admire you i admire you for being
a guy that
created and accomplished some [ __ ]
that is a phenomenon i want to shake
your hand
i would love to talk one day kev hey man
good meeting
you quite sure we'll bump past one day
hey if we do or don't you gonna remember
this
i just want to tell you i admire you i
don't need
i'm not asking for anything but what i
did
i set myself up for another conversation
for when i got the opportunity
you're talking here but i'ma come over
man i admire you
i want to ask you a bunch of questions
about this amazon
and that's how you came up with it i
don't think this is a time of place but
i want you to see my face
now i've got a special bonus on how to
practice that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know which
of these five ways are you going to use
to become a better communicator let me
know put it down the comments below and
if you made it this far in a video
you're still here watching i want to
celebrate you because believe nation we
don't just watch videos we do
something about it so that's you and you
commit you promise you're going to take
action immediately after watching this
video give me a hashtag believe down in
the comments and tell me where you're
from
because i want to celebrate you i'm
going to give you three of mine on how
to be a convincing communicator
step number one is have a powerful
opinion you have an opinion
what is it that you are trying to say
make it mean something to yourself
and to me and make that the first
sentence of every piece of content that
you make
if you're doing a video that's your
first sentence you do an instagram post
put it in there
you do a linkedin post an email a
newsletter like
put it in there you lead with your
powerful opinion
on what is wrong with the world or what
your viewpoint on xyz topic
is make it mean something to me make me
care so if i'm talking about
communication how important it is for
entrepreneurs
a powerful opinion would be something
like you need to learn
how to communicate in your business or
you will never get that idea that's in
your head
out into the world and your idea will
die inside you
that's an opinion where lots of people
might say something like
so if you want to learn
how to build a successful business and
maybe take
your idea to the next level i think
maybe
you should focus on trying to improve
how you
speak and communicate like it's so long
it has lots of filler words
you use words like maybe and potentially
and someday and one day and i wish
and we instead of i like affirmative
stop worrying about what people's
reactions are going to be and speak your
truth
always lead with a powerful opinion tip
number two is emotional commitment
this is where a lot of entrepreneurs
really fall down you've got your
powerful opinion you know what you stand
for you know what you're trying to
communicate
but when you get in front of a camera or
when you get down to writing
it doesn't sway people it's not
emotional enough you could be saying
all the best words when you get in front
of a camera to make a video
but because you are talking in a very
boring very non-exciting manner
and because you're so worried about
saying the perfect words
that you are memorizing something or you
are
looking at your script or trying to read
from a teleprompter
nobody is going to care or listen to you
you need to have emotional commitment
you need to feel the thing
and how important it is while you are
saying it for me
i'm envisioning all of you i'm
envisioning all the entrepreneurs that
i've worked with who have
these amazing ideas and they never get
them out because they can't communicate
and even though i'm sitting here in an
office by myself and there's nobody
around to actually connect with
i'm just talking to a camera i'm trying
to channel you i'm trying to channel all
the people that i've connected with
and seen and i want to make sure that
your business
does well and communicating is so
important as part of that which is why
i'm doing this video and hopefully the
care
the love the energy comes through in the
content that i make
and so sales and convincing people not
enough against
what they want but in a positive way
like this is something you guys can get
together on
is about the energy transfer you are not
just selling a concept or an idea you
are transferring energy
whoever is more confident wins whoever
is more convincing wins and it's usually
from
whoever believes in their thing more if
you absolutely believe in your thing and
that this
is right and it's for them and they need
to do this thing because it's in their
best interest not because they're just
trying to sell something
down their throat but you really really
really really care
and if they feel that care as opposed to
just
words that you're saying that's how you
bring them on board
it's great to have the best words but
more important is the emotional
commitment that you have
behind them so the best test with any of
this is watch back some of your content
like watch back your videos read your
newsletters see the copy on your website
look at the story that you wrote about
yourself and why you started this
business does it get you excited it's
like boom boom boom boom boom boom like
yes
that's right that's why i do this thing
or do you watch it and you get bored
if you get bored and it doesn't get your
heart beating then do it again
do it again and do it again and do it
again and do it again
you will be one of your best critics you
will be one of your harshest critics
and so being able to look over your
content and get to the point where you
say
wow yeah i'm really proud of that
that's when you start to win and tip
number three is raise the stakes
just make it more important if you want
to move people
so often we're focused just on the
tactics the strategies here's the five
things that you need to do
and people say yeah yeah yeah great i
love those the five things awesome they
write them down and then they never do
anything about it you need to raise the
stakes you have to make it more
important you have to make me
feel the pressure that if i don't do
this thing that you want me to do
terrible things will happen
right so if i talk about how important
communication is
me just saying communication is really
important as an entrepreneur
here are the three ways to do it it's
not as powerful as
communication is one of the most
important skills that entrepreneurs need
to have because if you don't learn
how to communicate your idea and get it
out there that idea
will die inside you and your mission
will never be realized
and listen that paints a dark picture
that's going to an extreme
and the idea is not to have hyperbole
and make things bigger than they are
but that's a real case for tons of
entrepreneurs
that if they do not learn how to
communicate properly their ideas will
never get out there and their idea will
die inside them
and so your goal if you want to move
people is to make them realize
how big this thing is for them if they
don't take action
you're the expert you know where the
road is going you see their future if
they continue down that path
they don't see that future they don't
understand it it's your job to help them
see where this current path of action is
going to lead them
and if they make the tweak they make the
change they take your recommendations
where it could go raise the stakes make
it more important
make them feel that it's more important
and it actually starts with you
feeling that this message is insanely
important
[Music]
if you want even more advice on how to
be a better communicator check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there so if you'll go to the very first
sentence in your note
the number one criteria for advancement
and promotion for professionals
is an ability to communicate effectively